you tube let's talk about some Punisher
this is gonna be my daredevil episodes 4
through 6 video I'll be talking about
Easter eggs just careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen them yet really the
first half of the episodes are setting
up the Punisher and slowly folding it
Elektra she doesn't show up till a
little bit later but towards the end of
this block of episodes she and Matt
actually start going on adventures but
let's start with the Punisher first
because he is fantastic so we start out
by meeting the Finn Cooley character
who's kind of like the big bad of this
Irish gang he is from The Punisher max
comics this is what his character looks
like you can see how when Punisher shot
him in the face they might have been
going for something like this I'm not
expecting him to come back surviving a
shotgun blast to the face is a bit
ridiculous and even though they did get
pretty fantastic with the things people
can survive by the end of the series I
don't really want to talk about spoilers
yet all I will say is that thing Cooley
here who actually played Vincent van
Gogh on Doctor Who which is really funny
when you consider what his character was
like on this was a pretty good medium
bad for the Punisher to go up against
definitely provided some opportunity to
find out if the Punisher really was that
crazy really it's when they threatened
to kill the dog that you learn about the
Punishers humanity he still has a soul
do whatever you want
just let the dog go the dog's name is
max he actually debuted during Punisher
vol 2 number 54 in 1991 so the dogs been
around for a while it actually kind of
serves the same purpose in the comics
that it is in the TV show just showing
you that there is a softer side to the
Punisher
but snarling attack dog is about as soft
as he gets and anybody who loves dogs
can't be that bad and anyone who harms
dogs is a terrible person which is why
using the dog in this scene worked so
beautifully because as crazy as the
Punisher is he still won't hurt an
animal I love the way they tell the
Punisher origin story like they spell it
out jumping back and forth between
Charon pages investigation in Frank
castles monologues we learned his family
was gunned down at this carousel in a
drug Buy gone wrong between three big
gangs and his family got caught in the
crossfire they were collateral damage
the DA's involvement in the mysterious
blacksmith character don't really get
explained till a little bit later so
I'll talk more about that in future
videos but you do learn that
is a cover-up at play but it all goes to
[ __ ] when Punishers trial turns into
this giant clown show and I'll see you
burn with the rest of them they really
do make the DA seem like a terrible
person
though matically she really is the jeryn
hogarth of this series and more Easter
eggs I know I'm gonna be posting my
arrow video later tonight Marc
Guggenheim showrunner of arrow also
wrote the issue the trial of the
Punisher which is heavily part of this
Big Punisher arc he didn't write for
daredevil season 2 though I'm sure he
was smiling when he saw the episodes but
when there newscasting about the
Punisher this person who is the
broadcaster is actually the same
newscaster for a bunch of different
Marvel Cinematic Universe productions
this person is actually a news anchor in
real life but they've been into the
Avengers Iron Man 3 in the amazing
spider-man 2 so they've been like
Marvel's go-to news broadcaster for all
their big movies the only thing I really
felt like without a place with the
Punisher storyline was the way they
aligned Karen page with his character I
really like that they gave her a story
they gave her a lot more agency she's
not the damsel in distress anymore but
the problem is is that her
characterization is that she's kind of
the angel on mat shoulder Elektra is
meant to be the daredevil Punishers the
agent of chaos and by aligning her
character with Punisher
he had really awesome scenes but it
makes her character seem like less of an
angel when that's really meant to be her
role in the story like in keeping with
the heavy-handed religious themes you
have angel and devil on both sides of
him pulling at him to cross the line do
I kill people do I not kill people
Karen Paige is really meant to embody
all the wonderful things in his life all
the good decisions but because the show
Alliance are with the Punisher it kind
of metals the metaphor a little bit but
that's okay season two Karen page is
still way better than season 1 Karen
page but let's talk about Elektra now
because I felt like the actors did an
amazing job and I did like the way they
weaved her in if they didn't change a
few things about the comics I was
totally cool with most of the changes
they made now I'm not talking about any
of the later episodes this is just
episodes 4 to 6 really like her initial
introduction in the backstory about her
and Matt during college now in the
context of the show I can't really
explain exactly what was going on the
first time they met without giving away
spoilers for later episodes because
there is a twist with her character that
you don't really learn about till the
very end
but suffice to say the energy that she
brings to Daredevils life is just
so much fun just the way they learn
about each other and you learned that
she really was the worst thing that
could have happened to him even though
he thought at the time she was the best
thing in present day matt has kind of
sworn her off like I don't want have
anything to do with you you're a
terrible influence on me I did terrible
things when I was with you like the
terrible girlfriend that you're trying
to forget but you can't stop being in
love with she really gives us some of
our most fun
daredevil present-day moments when
daredevil is having fun being daredevil
it's not like some burden that he has to
put on the mask and save people favorite
overall daredevil Elektra team-up moment
is their spy craft at Roxon which is
actually a big comic book Easter Egg
Roxon is one of the big evil
corporations that shows up a lot in Iron
Man stories they've been used in a
number of different big ways just like
Elektra explains on the show they have
their hands and a lot of very sinister
pies it's the exact same thing in the
comics more Easter eggs Brosco Sweeney
who is the person who allegedly killed
Matt's dad he's a character from the
comics
his name is The Fixer in the comic
version of the story he hired another
person named Slade to kill Matt's dad so
he didn't kill him directly we do start
to learn a little bit about the hand
steak slowly comes back into the picture
but that's really part of the Elektra
arc that gets played out over like the
last block of episodes so we'll talk
about that a little bit more in my next
video but let me know like as part of
this trial of the Punisher him getting
thrown in gen-pop meeting Elektra what
did you guys favorite thing about these
middle episodes really I just I loved
the chemistry between Matt and Elektra
it's so electric and there are a couple
times when they use electric electric
pawns which was kind of nice we should
all be so lucky to have such a terrible
girlfriend we'll have to talk about the
ramifications in the changes they made
to the comics based on what's going on
with six storyline in my next video so
what's gonna happen is my next video
will be episode 7 through 9 with Easter
eggs really my only complain about this
block of episodes is making Karen page
so sympathetic with the Punisher I
understand why they did it
but it really puts her in this morally
gray area where I don't think that she's
meant to be they do tease her backstory
a little bit we also don't really find
out why she's so guilty till later it
has to do with her backstory and in the
calm
she does have a troubled backstory but
it's not the terribad Frank Miller Karen
page backstory it has nothing to do with
that
what's gonna happen later tonight is
there's a new episode of arrow so be
sure to subscribe to get that all posted
after it airs I'll try to get my next
arrow devil video out in the next day or
two I'm gonna be posting my non-spoilery
Batman V Superman review on Thursday
night then after that I'll do an Easter
Egg spoiler review there's a lot of
things being said about the film
generally you're better off not reading
a lot of reviews before you go see the
movie but I am really excited and I'm
not really sure when my agents of shield
video from this week is gonna post so
I'll try to post an update on that later
tonight on Twitter and Facebook the
links for that are in the bottom of the
description even though I haven't talked
about the last couple of episodes I will
say that the cast has already started
talking about things happening through
season 4 so there definitely will be a
season 3 at least I don't know what's
gonna happen beyond that I think they'll
keep making it as long as the stars want
to keep making it so while you guys wait
for my next video to post you can click
here for all my daredevil videos and you
can click here for last night's episode
of the flash thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you